what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we are going to
watch from new rockstars she-hulk
trailer easter eggs and breakdown some
goodies to be had for sure if you can
leave a like that'd be great hulk smash
that subscribe button to get notified
when our next reactions for anything
that you're interested
are
up here yeah let's get to it
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for she-hulk on disney plus
starring tatyana maslany as jennifer
walters attorney at law cousin to bruce
banner and uh someone for whom my
admiration i swear to you remains a
wholesome professional respect
cgi we just may be better off in the
uncanny valley right now because uh if
this looked too lifelike major portions
of the productivity in america would
have come to a screeching halt when this
trailer dropped from the return of tim
roth as emil blonsky abomination to
frogman sightings and precisely why the
cgi might be a little off in some spots
i'm gonna break down this trailer frame
by frame for the details that you missed
let's go
being a superhero
there's a trial by fire
who's gonna protect the world if not
people like you
so we open on the la skyline already a
bit of a change to the pace for the mcu
which hasn't really been in the modern
day la area since iron man yeah i've
been saying that a lot giving the hero
talk to his cousin jennifer as a fancy
event comes under siege this actually
looks like the event that jen later in
this trailer attends in her nice dress
and now outside we see these armored
soldiers carrying these interesting
looking weapons these actually look like
a smaller handheld version of the song
from the incredible general ross used on
hulk in the 2008 which according to that
movie's opening credits actually came
from a stark industry's design they
showed up later equipped on the stark
drones in spider-man far from home and
war machine suit had a version of this
in civil war in this case it looks like
a defensive measure used against hulk
powered threats maybe she-hulk or
titania then we see this gang carrying
some interesting weapons a crossbow what
kind of threat are they facing if not a
supernatural one like vampires or
werewolves there's an eccentric mix of
tones in this trailer perhaps reflecting
this series format as a nine episode
half hour legal comedy with jen taking
on a new case of the week each week
which all could showcase a different
aspect of the marvel world vampires
specifically have come up more and more
like in loki and eternals eternals of
course introduced blade in its
post-credits scene we saw a crossbow and
sync them undercropped and spiders
place to introduce these different
things that's so funny because a lot of
us were feeling like the she-hulk
trailer seemed to be the lightest of
them all and not really a game changer
of sorts but if this ends up being that
half hour comedy show that introduces a
new quality of the mcu every time this
could be one of the most expansive
live-action series yet to come which
would be very unexpected from its first
look in all honesty but yeah based off
of the weapons that we're seeing here
and kind of that neo-noir vampire
blade-ish type of
looking vibe i guess so sure why not
let's go there let's go out this game
may also be the wrecking crew from the
comics also known for wielding crowbars
or they could just be another group of
guys carrying weird [ __ ] then we see a
custom bro which might be part of the
inciting incident of jen's
transformation now in the comics
jennifer walters as a prosecutor
cracking down an organized crime ends up
getting targeted by the mafia in shock
leaving to her cousin bruce having to
give her a transfusion and that blood is
how she ends up getting her hulk powers
however later in this trailer jen
appears outside that car looking at the
dark reflection in the dented car door
and she already begins to transform
she's already surrounded by green
transfusion before this or it may just
be innate to her family dna perhaps
activated by that shock wave of gamma
radiation when hulk snapped everyone
named which is interesting talk
indicated the radiation's mostly gamma
it's like uh
i was made for this so the uniqueness of
banner's blood that initially reacted to
the game of radiation in a specific way
to turn him into hulk maybe the same
unique dna trait that is also in jen's
blood and now that everyone on earth has
been hit with game of radiation it just
caused her to react this specific way we
get a quick shot of jen's whole physique
i have been bringing up the snap
and i just love how she's wearing the
white purple and black color scheme as
she does in her long time clothes in the
comics i hate how she's actually in
shorts and not like a one piece
yeah showing up
her v line
i think it's just disrespectful to the
source material is where i'm coming from
it's disrespectful nothing else to all
of the beach culture of the 80s and 90s
workout culture etc you know if you want
authenticity you go with the onesie that
reveals the anatomy how can we empower
women
as a guy i know how how can we empower
women if we don't show off their bodies
cover up people and inspect them to feel
empowered
stupid marvel moving on
i'm jennifer walters i'm a lawyer i have
great friends can we get some shots
please it's an emergency a demanding job
we just started a superhuman law
division and i want you to be the face
of it
okay the marvel studios title card turns
a bright shade of green and white
monday of light from beneath marvel
suggesting that yeah it might be a burst
of gamma radiation that was the cause of
jen's transformation jen introduced
played by ginger gonzaga they have open
wine bottles all over the house and the
wine bottle to the right is the velvet
devil label stop putting devil fake outs
in all your trailers just making them
angry roots are all aimed directly at
you yeah i'm assuming a legal colleague
of jennifer's in her office is an
hourglass because she's obviously a tva
agent uh please click away if i don't at
least mention these things he punishes
me but it's worth noting
represents a variety of clients working
one case in front of the tva another
time representing eros in a sexual
assault case oh my probably not going to
be in the mcu that's how errors gets
reintroduced
you can see on the screen it shows glk
h in the same design as the title card
for this series that thankfully now has
been updated because i like this new
title way better glkh stands for goodman
lieber kurtzberg and holloway which is
the name of jen's law firm in the 2004
run of the comics by dan slott now the
name goodman was a reference to marvel
publisher martin goodman lieber a
reference to stan lee's actual last name
stanley martin lieber and kurtzberg a
reference to jack kirby's legal last
name kurtzberg in the comics these three
partners are never happy
with your last three letters are grouped
together holloway is the only partner
who jen deals with when jen and nikki
get shots jen's clothes are actually
she-hulk's color scheme once again laser
white shirt fun green pants and purple
light on her shirt i like that random
trope where like characters before they
get their official outfit their actual
normal everyday attire is already
reflective of the color scheme it's as
if they were destined to become them
just like when goku went to high school
in dragon ball evolution that's right
and then eventually
got those colors but on the actual
uniform that orange and blue he put his
hoodie up and you're like whoa oh it's
just like the cartoon when's that gonna
show back up he's dusted for oh my god
then we see this awesome new maximum
security facility located in the middle
of the desert with high perimeter walls
and an energy field fence on the
drive-in this interesting architecture
makes me wonder if this could be the mcu
version of the cube originally a shield
black site in the nevada desert designed
to contain gamma irradiated inmates and
also become the home base of the
thunderbolts the patches on the guard
cool
it looks a lot like the us department of
justice but this isn't the dodc that has
a different logo whereas sword was
overseen by hayward and now perhaps
either monica rambo or abigail brand
maybe nick fury the raft prison was
overseen by secretary of state thaddeus
ross r.a.p william hurt this agency may
be under the supervision of val someone
we know was involved in some shady
government agency and you could totally
imagine julie louis-dreyfus showing up
in the series yeah the whole
conversation about like thunderbolts or
dark avengers has been
kind of getting dropped a little bit but
with you bringing up cube and then even
the facility fully representing that and
the fact that we also got emil blonsky
back in the game
you're wrong i just want to say you're
100 there's no way that's possible eric
no you're way off way off it's mephisto
train all over again that's right that's
what mephisto wants you to think it's
going to be the thunderbolt setup and
it's not the greatest trick that the
devil ever pulled was
making you the thunderbolts thinking you
think of thunderbolts back at the firm
jen's supervisor is holloway that being
the same holloway partner of this firm
name and it sounds like they're now
branching out to handle cases pertaining
to superheroes the same kind of legal
work provided by matt murdock in
spider-man no way home now while i
imagine matt murdock would stick to the
new york area it's really only a matter
of time before these two marvel lawyers
cross paths so it was at the premiere
for the truth now holloway specifically
wants janet to be the face of the
superhero law division suggesting that
this may come about after her tendency
to poke out emerges it looks like one of
her clients is emil blonsky aka
abomination tim roth returning from the
2008 hulk film now remember abomination
ended that film getting ko'd by hulk in
the battle of harlem and was actually
later the plan recruited by shield for
one of the avengers until we saw in that
marvel one shot coulson selvik used tony
stark to talk ross into recruiting bruce
banner instead blonsky was name dropped
in an episode of agents of shields
apparently kept in a cold storage
facility in alaska and of course we last
saw abomination in chongqi sparring with
wong in the golden daggers club of macau
actually win wong opened that portal to
take abominations
that's right
that's crazy
now wong is confirmed to appear in this
series as well so we'll likely get some
money
nomination in that movie was sneaking
around face four is about long approved
by the government i'm wondering if these
furloughs were actually part of a deal
to train up abomination as a government
soldier as part of val's dark avengers
crew maybe alongside elena belova and
john walker maybe blonsky now what's out
of that deal and that's why he is now
lawyering up either way i hope we get
some kind of rematch between whole
nomination in the series yeah that is a
rematch between them to pull all the
focus
off
the people
yeah i'm still questioning though why
would they fight in the tournament
betting round arena area then
yeah why wouldn't it just have a
training program thinking yeah why would
they just spar
in the facility where he's at
instead of going making a spectacle
maybe the government needs that extra
money they're like if blonsky wins we
keep the earnings you know yeah
fascinating i mean the road there let's
see the fight let them fight moving on
and a frustrating family because we
didn't ask for this
but you still got to deal with it okay
jennifer visits bruce in his new home on
this tropical coastline not sure where
exactly this is but later she is gonna
say
mexico so this may be along the mexican
coastline like the yucatan maybe one of
the places banner stopped during his
journey from brazil to the us in the
2008 film let's not forget all of that
happened in the mcu even though it feels
like so long ago bruce pulls out a
binder probably containing his research
that he conducted over that 18 months in
the gamma lab
when he found some mysterious cure to
reach his current balance and control
over his hulk abilities and he says you
didn't ask for this so it really does
sound like the series might be
suggesting jen's hulk powers could start
with a unique quality to their family
dna which is only now activated by a
recent burst of gamma radiation now
notice how the shots here are taken from
two different scenes one where hulk is
wearing a zip-up hoodie another where
he's wearing this t-shirt amazing that
he found that oh
it's got an interesting logo at first i
thought this could be related to shield
but the bolts emanating out of it make
me wonder if this could actually be a
logo that he made for himself in his
gamma radiation like his new hulk logo
[Laughter]
i love the idea of hulk becoming a
graphic designer
i need to make this symmetrical simple
but cool the first month i figured it
all out it was really the next 17 months
where i was working on my design
myself in the public eye make myself
more personable to people to make make a
few extra bucks on the side now the
second scene looks like it is part of a
meditation session like he's like saying
relax breathe hulk could be teaching her
how to relax and center herself
meditation remember was a huge part of
bruce's regimen in the 2008 film now we
still do not know exactly why bruce was
shown in human form with his arm and a
sling in that shang-chi post-credits
scene especially now that he's back in
hulk for him with his arm completely
healed kevin feige told screenwrite that
that sling was intentional and i have
theorized that maybe hulk de-powered a
human form to allow himself to give a
life-saving transfusion to jen but the
imax aspect ratio of that chongqipo's
credit scene showed banner was also on
this other arm wearing a piece of wrist
tech with a glowing green piece to it
which now after doctor strange and the
multiverse madness has come out kind of
reminds us of those
conflicts that were powered by the green
that seemed shitty those sands
depowering the wearer for a certain
amount of time maybe wong gave banner
that cuff to depower him so that they
could temporarily heal his arm when he
was in human form because as whole his
flesh is otherwise so impenetrable they
couldn't really do anything to them
let's move on affirmations are triggered
by anger and fear
those are like the baseline of any woman
just existing
oh
i feel like if i don't transform i'm
gonna die
[Applause]
banner deliberately provides jen's anger
with this torture device their swim gear
indicates that this lab is underground
their tropical mexican home now whereas
in the november teaser the screens
beside banner showed jen's face here it
shows an x-ray of her brain with the
limbic system highlighted the limbic
system is the inner part of the brain
that controls as baby now says the hulk
abilities are activated by anger and
fear we flashback the emotional action
transformation and while she can't
exactly see a reflection fully the car
paint is green which masks her own skin
color change and yeah we see how this
chamber is a total death pod razor's
spinning if you look closely at those
razors when she breaks them especially
you can see they are stark industries
brand so this means tony stark may have
helped banner set up this gamma lab
during those 18 months working alongside
him as a lab partner and the graphic
successfully trigger the pier to
activate her she-hulk form banner gives
these thumbs up looking just as he did
to encourage the avengers during their
quantum experiment and end game and this
experiment is about as much of an
absolute win next clip i just want to be
a normal anonymous lawyer can you tell
us where she-hulk is jen you're a story
now
girl your ass looks crazy right now hey
we see janet what looks like her
childhood bedroom midsummer night's
stream there's a midsummer night's dream
which is a play all about physical
transformation and the sexual arousal
that arrives with it i assume jen might
be located here after getting some
unwanted media attention due to her
condition then we see jen and her
she-hulk form trying to go about her
work routine but finds herself just
getting stared at even that receptionist
snaps a photo using the flash with all
this great natural lighting come on yeah
what are you doing what are you doing
the unfinished cgi on she-hulk in her
face in this trailer i think it was
bound to happen it honestly doesn't
bother me as much as it does some of you
it really only strikes me in this one
shot of jennifer looking at her phone
it's not so much the animation it's
really just the timing and the movement
notice how her eyes are slightly out of
sync with her body as it moves like i
get it they're trying to animate this
gesture of jen reacting to something on
the phone and then her eyes gesture to
the side like what do i do but they dart
adds her body is still straightening up
which is
a little weirdly unnatural like if you
were animated in cartoon you would do
one move after the other you have the
back straighten and then the eyes start
to the side and due to the uncanny
valley effect that is encoded in our
brains our minds just weirdly accept
more cartoony blocking as more
naturalistic which is why when you watch
pixar animation they deliberately
animate their characters to move more
cartoony and slap sticky because we grew
up watching cartoons our brains just
kind of accept that as natural that's
why they call it the uncanny valley you
have to go a little bit beyond what
would be natural movement so that when
we watch animated green characters we
just accept it i i see this as an
absolute win i will say i really
appreciate that they designed she-hulk
to have proportionately large hands
because remember hulk spiffs are larger
than a human's hands would be compared
to the arms but the problem is you still
just don't get a sense of the weight of
the phone in her hands the way that they
show
the tacos or clutch the sausage rolled
in a pancake look again none of this is
that big of a deal i don't think they
are still rendering all these effects
ahead of august and i definitely don't
think this is sonic level bad so let's
just all chill out okay i mean it's
pretty well known at this point that the
vfx companies
are down to the wire these days i'm
expecting the effects to be better by
the time this show rolls around you know
like will it be a hundred percent better
maybe maybe not but i think it will be
better it didn't upset me or think my
arms get thrown up in the air like a lot
of people yeah because of the fact that
you know if you look into it it's it's
not just some rumor it's a fact that vfx
companies right now are backed up and so
they are a lot of the things they get
releases often like a week before when
they finally wrap this up and it's about
to release yeah absolutely and the other
thing too is this is a trailer it's
showing you these brief glimpses and i
feel like any effect like that that does
rest pretty close to a person's likeness
will get much better when you have a
breathing room of a scene when your
brain has time to process all that
because in a quick flash you don't have
that much time to process that well it's
like professor hulk looks or hulk in
general just looks so different than
mark ruffalo where she has to look a
little bit more akin just bigger yeah
there's less of a character aspect so
yeah it's harder to it's like he said
they don't go as far beyond the valley
so it's a trickier effect yeah and
ultimately i just applaud this series
for leaning into the tone of the
character she-hulk and especially the
overt sexuality of the character
something that the comics do not shy
away from as shiok was really an
intentionally campy satire of the way
comics as a whole would over sexualize
female superheroes sheol was really the
first superhero to completely own it and
make it a joke this show definitely
seems to be embracing that like the shot
of all the gawkers at the garden party
the woman on the left is the funniest to
me like come on guys up here lady next
clip
you could be an avenger oh i'm not a
superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
so jen bursts out of her shoes as
someone tries to attack her from behind
her growth lifting him off his feet this
attacker wears an interesting helmet
that emits an energy glow not sure what
this is oh i didn't notice that the
advanced hardware that adrian toomes
crew lifted from shitari tech and
spider-man homecoming mickey encourages
her to join the avengers as we see
she-hulk and hulk leaping beside each
other on that island in a training
montage and while hulk hits a superhero
landing i like him jen doesn't she just
kind of lands in this
elbows beneath her knees jen tells nicky
that the avengers are for billionaires
and narcissists and adult orphans
referring to well i guess tony stark who
was all of those things but also if you
think about it technically t'challa
might be the richest avenger if you
quantify the value of vibranium perhaps
and peter parker does this taking a
chance
one cannot help but think of orphan
black the series where she showcased her
amazing talent then
barefoot and closed torn suggesting she
was not prepared to hulk out here tears
across a damaged courtroom toward a
phone the other show reveals this is
titania yeah mary mcferrin she holds a
long time nemesis in the comics now
titania gets powered up by alien
technology and has powers at rival gents
it looks like she smashed into this
courtroom maybe to interrupt this trial
keep someone from testifying her outfit
looks wild something like a pro wrestler
that's funny to me is that parts of moon
knight with layla reminded me of wonder
woman and wonder woman 1984
like a better egypt version of that and
then parts of this trailer
remind me of wonder woman i did it for
with the parts with cheetah
that's what phase four is really about
is just doing better than wonder woman
woman stuff better than the
that's our barn we gotta clear it but
then there's a quick shot of this
leaping dude this is the fabulous frog
man eugene patillo one of the real
goofball marvel characters son of the
leapfrog vincent patillo eugene takes on
his dad's frog costume he adds these
spring coils so that it can leap six
stories in the air he's shown up with
spider-man the human torch as well as
the avengers of various comics i just
want to give a huge congrats to long
time frog man stan mt for frogman
finally getting his incentive
to take another one of jen's cases we
get a quick shot of abomination hulking
out in his containment cell ripping out
of his inmate jumpsuit as in the
character has been redesigned from the
2008 film to better match his comic
appearance he now has fins on the side
of his head and as he bumps his head the
red glow flashes over that container
cell meaning this cell may be equipped
to shock him with pain whenever he tries
to hulk out of it then on to the last
clip like superman anything more
depressing than dating in your 30s
yeah this is the best that i've had in a
while oh should we split some fries
let's get those to go
so jen swipes through a dating app on
her phone match her and i like how she
swipes right on everyone and there's
some great easter eggs here of course
scott dog lover eight miles away grant
jump rope king 12 miles away oh you're
trying to be clever there grant nick dj
60 miles away noah director 24 miles
away nice scarf noah but my favorite is
truck local cutie 32 miles away not
exactly local but this is actually a
cameo by series creator jessica gao's
partner artist truck torrents oh and
they're kind of whiskers truck and the
cat are wearing little captains hats to
salute the admiral so sweet of jessica
to get her local cutie in there now the
other name she swipes through
bryce charles chris kevin feige and
terry and then we show you these dates
including that rick who flexes this is
actually wwe wrestler david ortunga but
she ends the night with his other hunk
taking those fries to go the guy from
miracle workers carrying the beefcake
back to her room as his foot knocks the
lamp again folks a hard yes to more
sexual liberation rock hard yes
disney plus is gonna go so hard on that
sexual liberation he thought we were
gonna get violence in the mcu but nope
we're just gonna get more and more
titillation yo man if you thought they
were pushing boundaries with
gay
you ain't moms
nothing yet they're gonna go to the
bedroom and and then they're gonna fade
to black you remember that that love
scene in eternals we'll get ready for
almost that
again
phase four is the thirst phase oh you
guys you guys ain't seen [ __ ]
because otherwise this mcu until an
eternal sex scene was completely
puritanical we never got any sex in the
mcu sex is a normal part of adult life
it's
comment down below with your thoughts on
all this follow me on instagram and
twitter at ea boss following the
rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye good job eric
and the editors
eric and the editors eric and the
editors this friday at your local pub
guys it's great i'm excited for she-hulk
despite the fact it has the shittiest
vfx i've ever seen in my entire
existence on this client guard my
eyeballs
guys subscribe to new rock stars keep a
lookout for when we start covering this
show you can skip everything else until
august
let's go page
rosa parra my god this show is about a
strong woman
physically emotionally mentally that's
you rosa parra i'd like you to pick me
up and take me to the bedroom then when
you go to lay we down you go wait a
minute you're not john you're the other
guy
where's john then you throw me through
the ceiling falling onto your front lawn
then you go stampeding through the
streets knocking cars out of the way
find jaw rip him out of his bedroom
after there's a hole shaped rosa in the
wall and then you pick it on up take him
back to your bedroom as you're carrying
him like this in front of you and then
you throw him on the bed and then you
make love to him and go rosa parra gets
the man she wants
well i'm at your lawn crying your kids
are like mama
what are you doing because you're
italian now
and i'm like go away children it's okay
my mom just wants to make a love to a
different man she makes me cry she's
making me cry
nobody wants to make a love to me
hulk nut rosa thanks for being a strong
female presence
and rejecting me in the process
[Music]